im phoenix tagesgespräch ist uns jetzt
per internet zugeschaltet karl rudolf
korte er ist professor für
politikwissenschaften in duisburg herr
professor korte das tri l wie es ihre
einschätzung
naja die jagdsaison auf die spät
entscheider auf die noch unentschieden
ist offenbar eröffnet und viele
millionen menschen haben das gesehen das
ist sehr aufklärerisch denke ich schon
ein hochfest auch unser demokratie wenn
man solche formate über so lange zeit ja
erleben kann sie hat eine
unterhaltungswert es war voller
einzelner attacken aber es war im kern
vor allen dingen sehr informativ über
verschiedene themen bilde was möchten
sie da besonders hervorheben was ist
ihnen da aufgefallen naja die die erste
halbe stunde bezog sich vor allen dingen
auf die frage wie man mit politischem
vertrauen umgeht politik vertrauen in
den blick auf das was man als
leitungsaufgabe anvertraut bekommen hat
sie hat versucht das jetzt sehr stark
den
finanzminister zu attackieren mit seiner
historischen
mit den historischen fällen die er in
hamburg hat die von der warburg-bank als
thema aufgetischt worden von wirecard
bis hin zu den aktuellen
auseinandersetzungen
und das fand ich schon einen sehr
interessanten austausch dem wir in
dieser form bei den anderen trial so
nicht erlebt hatten weil er eben aus
sagt wie man mit attacken auch umgeht
wie krisenfest mann ist in der
auseinandersetzung und da wurden eben
bestimmte dinge sichtbar über die show
präsenz hinaus auch die sache
dokumentation zu kennen bei scholz war
insofern dann interessant wie er das
thema praktisch auf ein anderes gleis
gesetzt hat und gesagt hat welche
modernisierungs effekte er innerhalb der
organisation angesetzt hat um
vorzusorgen dass so etwas nie mehr
passiert
die attacken von armin laschet die kamen
ja nun wohl eher hinten liegt und
angriff ist ja vielleicht dann
irgendwann das einzige mittel der wahl
wenn man zurückliegt fanden sie die
glaubwürdig die attacken von armin
laschet ja
denn wie gesagt es muss darum gehen die
anhänger noch mal zu mobilisieren und
stellt unentschieden auf seine seite zu
bringen hier ist er in der defensive
durch umfragen und umfragen bestätigen
sich selbst man ist dann auch als
zuschauer in der rolle und guckt ob er
es schafft in die offensive zu kommen er
hat es eben geschafft scholz in der
ersten 20 minuten in die defensive zu
bekommen dass es im erstmals gelungen
das war eine neue facette die wir auch
bei scholz kennengelernt haben und
laschet hat insofern versucht ja eine
vorne verteidigung anzutreten mit mit
themen in denen er sich sicher fühlt der
industrie politisch einrahmt aus seiner
erfahrung aus nrw heraus insofern war
das sehr glaubwürdig dass er versucht
hat mit einer attacke auch in die
offensive zu kommen aber das war auch
erwartet worden weil er ja etwas tun
muss nicht nur um aufzufallen sondern
auch letztlich um themen zu setzen der
blitzumfragen sieger nenne ich mal so
war wieder einmal olaf scholz
finden sie diese stabilität die er da
beweist im auge der wähler erstaunlich
und wird sich dann noch mal was dran
ändern
wie sehen sie das
naja verkörpert das merke liste
sicherheitsgefühl von allen dreien
sofern bedient er ein muster des wählens
in deutschland das bekannte nicht das
unbekannte und auch vom typus her so
etwas
ja einen tadel stärker zu favorisieren
als große veränderung aktivisten und
diese art kommt ihm entgegen weil er
auch mit so einer asiatischen
unterkühltheit unterwegs ist dass viele
denken das ist vielleicht eine
fortsetzung von stabilität er hat das
meiste von merkel in der fortsetzung
enkel haft geradezu an sich und so das
ist die projektion die viele wähler und
weder haben wenn sie so etwas sehen dann
hat man im hintergrund die umfragewerte
und das stabilisiert sich wechselseitig
dass eine prophezeiung die dann ende
auch sich selbst trägt und sofern sich
auch verstärkt da etwas gegen zu machen
da müssen ganz große fehler dann auch
scholz passieren
aussetzer eine große erinnerungslücken
oder
völlig falsche formulierungen oder das
er selbst aus der rolle fällt das ist
aber bei ihr nicht zu sagen das kann man
sich nicht so richtig vorstellen wie ihr
bisher agiert hat ganz kurz wenn sie uns
noch zum schluss ganz kurz nochmal zu
annalena baerbock ihre eindrücke
schildern kanzlerin wird sie ja nun
nicht mehr das geben die umfrage nicht
gerne
sie stand in der mitte sie hat manchmal
moderiert aber sie hat auch ihre themen
beim umweltthema aus meiner sicht sehr
gut gesetzt insofern kann es ja auch
sein dass sie nicht nur gebraucht wird
wie viele koalition sondern vielleicht
können wir auch diese kenia keine
koalition die dort stand am ende auch
für eine regierungsbildung in betracht
ziehen herr professor korte herzlichen
dank ihnen nach duisburg